so now this dudes on top me trying to
bite my face off which didn't bother me
cuz dude was naked so the whole time I
could feel his and balls slamming
against my thigh
welcome if this is not happening
I'm your host Roy Wood jr. hey there you
go boys drink up nobody's gonna remember
what the hell's happening tonight that
dudes trying to get my couch pregnant
he's peeing out the window oh come on
man John Legend bought me that piano put
on a ball pit
[Applause]
ting please give it up for Dave Landau
[Music]
as well as the rest of 13 times all for
alcohol convictions and this story is
about my sixth arrest when I was 17
years old I was at a house party I was a
really insecure kid so I would do
anything to get people to like me so
it's shocking that I became a comic and
now when I was the kiddos at this house
party my friend Nick goes hey Dave you
should bought a fifth and I was like
you're right so my friend Anthony held
out a beer bong and my friend Nick
poured in an entire fifth of absolute
vodka and then Nick goes dude this is
really stupid pour it in some sprite and
goes now you're good now I don't know if
you know what happens when you bong a
fifth
besides become a legend
I will tell you you tap danced for four
minutes you tell your girlfriend who you
love more than life itself that she has
orangutan titties you light a cigarette
by the filter and you pass out through a
glass table you wake up the next day to
the police and they know you they've
seen you many times and they're like hey
Dave and I'm just getting back
consciousness because all my friends
just took off you know the party
dispersed the parents came home and
we're like there's a dead kid in my
living room so they walk in and they're
like hey Dave and I'm like hey hey
fellas how are you and they go Dave
you're gonna go to real Jail and you're
a teenager like this is your sixth
arrest the judge hates you you're gonna
go to actual prison so we're gonna give
you one get-out-of-jail-free card right
now if you agree to go to a rehab and
change your life we will drive you there
and we will let you do that we will call
your parents figure out how you're gonna
pay for it but that's it right now
what's your choice jail or rehab and I
was like because are you seriously
thinking about I was like okay do they
but you in rehab because now when I
was like well thing let's do that one so
they handcuffed me to the inside of an
ambulance
and they drove me to a rehab but on the
way there they found out there were no
beds available so I had to be detoured
to a mental hospital which was their
sister hospital until a bed opened up so
we get to this hospital I'm getting
walked in by three cops handcuffed and
they take me to meet my counselor and
then that my counselor takes me to meet
my roommate I'm like roommates and
counselors this is going to be like camp
this is incredible she walked to this
back room there's two beds and our one
bed this kid's just kind of sitting
there staring
councillor goes Dave this is race race
Dave get to know each other you're going
to be roommates and Rhys goes woody in
for ah long to fifth I think I'm an
alcoholic of some kind I'm like what
about you he goes who me I'm a werewolf
see for real I go you don't look like a
werewolf man he goes yeah I'm not a
werewolf right now there's not a full
moon if there's a full moon I transform
into a werewolf and I attack people I
don't remember it last week I blacked
out and they told me I almost killed my
dad
Nate hey counselor Iona need my own room
this dude thinks he's a werewolf and he
goes oh he's not a werewolf you're gonna
be fine
okay I think he doesn't know he's not a
werewolf I'm kind of all set on that and
he goes I don't know what you're not
getting he's not a werewolf okay he's a
delusional schizophrenic with rage
issues okay well that's good but um I
just bone to fifth I'm not a crazy
person so if I could just get my own
room till I go to rehab he goes you got
brought in by cops handcuffed you're
probably more dangerous than him
everybody gets a roommate that's your
roommate and you just walked away now
being in a mental hospital is not that
bad I'm there two days you get to wear
pajamas you watch a lot of TV you can't
eat anything with a knife because people
get shanky and they take your shoelaces
on account of the hangings better than
that it's totally normal Hospital and
one night I'm going to bed and all of a
sudden from the next bunk I just hear
[Music]
good nervous
this dude stands up rips all of his
clothes off walks to the edge of the bed
and starts barking at me just going and
I'm like yeah werewolf
there's a werewolf where this dude
lunges at me butt-naked I grabbed a lamp
to hit him with it and it's
glued down so now this dude's on taught
me trying to bite my face off which
didn't bother me cuz dude was naked so
the whole time I could feel his and
balls slamming against my thighs while I
yelled werewolf werewolf over and over
again two counselors bust in the door
see him naked on top May and I swear to
God one let's say the other one who goes
do we let him finish
so I gotta know anyone today I'm like
we're not having sex he wants the murder
rate please he thinks is a wolf please
they hit him an ant in the answer the
syringe it's filled with something
called booty juice which they swear to
God they give it to mental patients when
they go file ined and this dude goes
limp all of him instantaneously they
pull him off I stood up I'm in tears I'm
like I don't want to bear I'm an
alcoholic
I'm so scared you have me rooming with
monsters I would have rather gone to
prison
I don't wanna be here I don't wanna be
oh my god take me home please no more
roommates oh there's the wolf dick
mushroom print on my thigh
no more roommates no so then I go to bed
with with the help of antipsychotics and
after a kind of a still tossie tourney
night sleep I wake up next day and they
bring in my new roommate no hey Dave
this is Keith Keith Dave get to know
each other you're gonna be roommate
Keith oh dude what's your problem what's
my route last night I got attacked by a
goddamn werewolf and then Keith looks to
the counselor and goes hey ma'am I need
my own room and that's how they make
crazy people
[Applause]
and I tell you that story to tell you
this one I was not a good student if you
can believe it I spent five years in
high school which I'm told is too many
and I always again I always wanted
attention I was wanting people to like
me and I had a class called humanities I
don't know if you ever had it I don't
know what the it is but I had the
class and one day I came into class and
the teacher wasn't there and there's a
blank chalkboard so I'm like why should
you know draw a dick so I just drew a
dick you know and the teacher comes in
and she's like the next day come in
there's no teacher so I'm like yeah draw
a dick day number three I'm like is this
a miracle it didn't more Dec now this
goes on for three months and I'm not
just drawing it on the chalkboard I'm
hiding it in books I'm putting it on
like the door balls on the knob like
it's just ridiculous and I'm putting it
like on her desk just drawing dicks
dicks dicks and this goes on for three
months then one day she comes into class
and there's an overhead projector setup
she walks up and expecting a dick no
dick she breathes a sigh of relief and
then she turns around and pulls down the
screen boom
permanent marker deck two different
colors I even had purple for the vane
here's the thing though she loses her
mind she goes who is doing this
which one of you are doing this who is
doing this which one of you are the
penis master who is the penis master
where is the penis master I want to meet
the penis master at this point there's
people coming out other classrooms like
someone's yelling penis master
there's janitors going by like I'll be
your penis master who is the penis
master she is on her knees crying
mascara running down her face I felt so
horrible I finally stood up and I'm like
I am the penis master she goes all hail
the penis master I'm like this is
weird
she has come down to the office with me
right now we go into the principal's
office
she walks me and she goes tell them tell
them who you are
I am the penis master he goes that's
great Dave so she tells him what
happened he writes down on a suspension
slip Dave is suspended for one week
because he likes drawing male genitalia
all over his classroom he hands it to me
goes don't come back until your parents
sign it and I'm suspended when I come
back I get suspended again because when
I handed him the slip I did not have my
parents sign it
instead I drew it dick I come back a
week later and I finally go back to the
class and the teachers gone and I'm like
whoa this is weird like what happened
and they're like yeah Dave she's she
wasn't saying don't like wait what do
you mean she went like they're like dude
she didn't think you acted alone there
were so many dicks like she thought she
thought there was another gunner on the
grassy knoll she just started asking
kids if they were the penis master and
they had to let her go to get
psychiatric care like you drove her nuts
with dicks which means that at some
point in a mental hospital in Michigan
in the late 90s
my teacher could have walked up to a kid
and said are you the penis master and he
was like who me now I'm a werewolf thank
you guys very much